[Musique]
ce que vous venez de voir c'est un peu
mon pire cauchemar pour tous nos sols en
version très gentil plus spécifiquement
le jour où la vidéo numéro 1 de
tournesol est une vidéo raciste
pédophiles ou conspirationnistes double
projet pourra être des clés débit lisez
et pour tout vous dire c'est déjà un peu
arrivé il ya quelques mois lorsque notre
algorithme interprovincial était encore
plein de bugs
bon la vidéo problématique était pas
tout à fait numéro 1 mais je n'ai eu des
sueurs froides
bref tout ça pour dire que la sécurité
de tournesol et des recommandations
faites par tournesol
c'est une préoccupation majeure du
projet il est absolument critique que
les scores calculé par tournesol soit
parfaitement sécurisé et ne conduise pas
à des recommandations dangereuse et
malheureusement garantir la sécurité des
scores c'est une tâche extrêmement ardue
sachant qu'on veut également qu'il soit
déterminé par les jugements de nos
contributeurs et qu'on ne connaît pas
personnellement nos contributeurs
en fait même si on les connaissait
personnellement ne pourra jamais exclure
la possibilité que lors qu'on se fasse à
quai et qu'ils soient exploitées par des
entités extrêmement malveillantes dans
le langage de l'algorithmique est parti
de telles entités maxime allemand
malveillantes
c'est ce qu'on appelle des byzantins
notamment après que leslie emporte a
voulu illustrer la difficulté de
concevoir des solutions en présence de
byzantin viennent de fable qu'on appelle
désormais le problème des généraux
byzantin qui vous sort par le jour le
problème c'est que sur internet les
byzantins
c'est la norme rappelez vous de ce qu'on
me disait dans le premier épisode de
cette série sur facebook
malgré tout les contrôles et malgré des
énormes équipe d'ingénieurs dédié à
l'identification des faucons il y a très
certainement beaucoup plus de faux
compte que deux comptes associés et des
utilisateurs humain authentique
en 2010 neuf seulement facebook avait
ainsi retiré 6 milliards de faux comptes
de la sorte on retrouve également
certainement des attaques massives par
fo compte sur des sites comme amazon ou
tripadvisor et ça ne devrait pas être
étonnant sachant les intérêts
économiques énormes les industriels et
des restaurateurs pour booster leurs
scores et sachant la facilité avec
laquelle il est possible de créer des
faux comptes sur ces plateformes
de façon plus générale toute plate forme
web collaborative
influente doit s'attendre à ce que toute
sorte d'entité malveillantes recherche
et exploiter vulnérabilité de la
plateforme en particulier si leur est
possible de créer des faux comptes pour
manipuler les scores de tournesol par
exemple pour promouvoir deux vidéos qui
lie le changement climatique il faut
s'attendre à ce qu'ils ont énormément
d'argent à dépenser pour y arriver y
parviennent surtout le jour où tournesol
deviendra connu et influents et dans le
cas où tournesol ne serait pas
suffisamment sécurisé
m
un lieu d'expression en particulier pour
parler du cas où les bisontins prennent
complètement le contrôle d'un projet
collaboratif
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tacc des 51%
ici illustrée dans le cas de l'internet
décentralisée fictif conçu par les héros
de la série silicon valley qui s'appelle
tide piper initialement protégé par un
système de permissions la sécurité de
piper et tout à coup violet est une
entité malveillantes cherchent alors à
prendre son contrôle pour faire cracher
tout pas peur mais pour y arriver dans
la série il suffit en fait à l'entité
malveillante de connecter plus de
machines horizon qu'il n'y en avait
initialement une telle attaque d'appeler
une attaque des 51% et ce n'est bien sûr
pas du tout spécifiques au monde
numérique en démocratie aussi si une
idéologie ou mes informations par bien
conquérir 51 % des citoyens
alors elle pourra en principe contrôler
la politique du pays
même si en pratique et toute sorte de
contre-pouvoir empêche généralement
contre total des organismes gouvernants
du pays comme par exemple les autorités
sanitaires qui ne dépendent pas
directement de la volonté démocratique
mais cette attaque des 51% ne se
restreint pas non plus à la démocratie
par exemple dans la série soute
les personnages principaux cherchent eux
aussi à garder le contrôle de leur
entreprise en s'assurant qu'aucun tival
ne réussisse à gagner le coeur de 51% du
conseil d'administration qui a le
pouvoir suprême sur l'entreprise
ceci étant dit c'est surtout dans le
monde numérique et en particulier dans
celui des crypto monnaie que le risque
d'attaquer les 51% est devenu une
obsession
après tout si l'entité parvient à
effectuer une attaque des 51% sur le
bitcoin alors les 18 millions de bitcoin
en circulation qui valent 40000 euros
chacun représentant ainsi un total de
700 milliards d'euros tous ces bitcoin
ne vaudrait tout à coup presque plus
rien du tout parce que l'attaquant
pourra frauduleusement supprimer les
transactions qui l'arrangent et
décrédibiliserait ainsi toute la
sécurité du bitkom 700 milliards d'euros
pourrait disparaître du jour au
lendemain en cas d'attaqué
51% autant dire beaucoup de
milliardaires prenne de risques de la
taille des 51% très au sérieux
très rapidement les informatique
ce rendu compte que pour se protéger
d'une attaque les 51%
il est nécessaire de rendre difficile la
participation aux prochaines
collaborative en effet autrement
n'importe qui pourrait créer un grand
nombre de faux comptes pour contrôler
51% des comptes et prendre ainsi le
contrôle du projet collaboratif telle
création massive de faux comptes et
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle une attaque
sybille la solution trouvée par le bit
qu elle pour rendre difficile une telle
participation est de réutiliser ce qui
fut utilisé pour empêcher l'envoi massif
de spams cette solution est ce qu'on
appelle le proof of work proulx favorite
c'est un problème difficile qu'on
demande aux participants de résoudre
pour pouvoir participer
dans le cas des emails le problème en
question n'est pas si difficile mais il
faut quand même quelques secondes aux
machines modernes pour le résoudre
dans le cas du big town de près mais
beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile puisque
dix minutes sont nécessaires pour une
armée de machines pour qu'enfin le
résoudre c'est ce prof à warcq qui
permet au beacon d'être devenu le
système informatique le plus fiable et
le plus résilient jamais créés à ce jour
contrairement à google par exemple en
l'espace de plus de 10 ans bitcoin mais
jamais connu aucune panne
malheureusement le pouvoir qu'a aussi
d'énormes défauts pour commencer il est
extrêmement polluant puisqu'il amène de
nombreuses machines à faire d'énormes
calcul juste pour participer au bitcoin
est aidé à le sécuriser
et pour le coup on parle de calcul est
donc de pollution absolument
gargantuesque on estime ainsi que le
bitcoin consomme plus d'énergie que
l'argentine
par ailleurs le pouf avoir qui permet
surtout à ceux qui possèdent le plus de
puissance de calcul de contrôler le
beach boys et au final ça et
correspondent à ceux qui ont le plus
d'argent
pas sûr qu'il soit souhaitable pour tous
les projets collaboratifs d'être
contrôlés ou du moins contrôlable par ce
qu'ils sont capables de dépenser plus
d'argent
en tout cas je préfère que tournesol ne
soit pas vulnérables ou milliardaires
bref pour nous protéger de la tacc des
51%
il nous faut absolument des solutions
plus éthiques les alternatives classique
considéré par les cathos monnaie comme
le pronostiquent loufoque bord le prix
fort space ou encore le pauvre ban whif
ce sont des solutions qui me semble très
insatisfaisante
à cet égard
il yal recherché par tournesol est ce
qu'on appelle le proof of first blood
idéalement il faudrait qu'on soit en
mesure de prouver que chaque compte
validé sur tournesol est contrôlé par un
utilisateur humain mais aussi et surtout
que cet utilisateur humain ne contrôle
aucun autre compte sur tournesol
en gros on veut la même condition que le
vote citoyen en démocratie notez que
cette seconde condition exclu en
particulier les solutions à base de cap
chat qui consiste à vérifier que
l'utilisateur et humain cependant de
tels systèmes utilisés notamment par
facebook peuvent être largement
attaquées par des fermes ta clique où un
grand nombre d'employés humains sont
payés pour ouvrir de nouveaux comptes
sur une plateforme données
malheureusement en trouver une solution
pour le profond crosswood est encore un
énorme défi de la recherche moderne
si certains pays se mettent à concevoir
de tels systèmes d'identité numérique
n'existe cependant pour l'instant aucune
solution simple à utiliser et quand bien
même ces systèmes
existerait il faudrait absolument
veiller à ce qu'ils soient parfaitement
sécurisée pour tournesol l'une des pires
choses qui puisse arriver serait par
exemple que toutes les identités en inde
soit violée par un bisontin qui les
utiliseraient pour manipuler à sa guise
les scores tournesol
pour toutes ces raisons la solution
aujourd'hui implémentée par tournesol et
la validation du mail associée à des
noms de domaine de confiance comme le
pfl conseil âge où as tu des 400 points
fr en particulier pour protéger
tournesol de l'attak des 51 % jugent la
probabilité qu'un byzantin puisse créer
un grand nombre de faux comptes
rattachés à ce nom de domaine
c'est pour cela que des noms de domaine
comme athlète gmail.com ne sont pas
considérés digne de confiance
c'est aussi pour cela que des noms de
domaine comme adsense for all point org
ne sont pas non plus considérer digne de
confiance non seulement le propriétaire
de ce nom de domaine pourrait créer
plein d'e-mails avec soin de domaines
mais surtout s'il n'est pas un expert en
sécurité informatique
il pourrait ainsi se faire hacker parent
byzantin qui créerait plein 10 mai avec
ce nom de domaine
alors bien sûr malheureusement ce mode
de certification est aussi très
restrictif
je présente mes excuses auprès de tous
ceux parmi vous qui souhaiteraient
participer mais ne dispose pas du mail
associée à des noms de domaine de
confiance ceci étant sur tournesol ou
dispose désormais d'autres méthodes de
validation de compte il est ainsi
désormais possible de devenir garant
d'autres comptent ainsi si votre couvent
votre ami es sur tournesol
alors vous pouvez
allez sur sa page tournesol et dire un
tournesol que vous certifier le fait que
l'utilisateur du compte est un humain et
que ses utilisateurs ne possède qu'un
seul compte actif sur tournesol un
utilisateur qui possède suffisamment de
garanties vérifier sera alors considéré
vérifier à son tour tournesol envisage
aussi un système de validation par
téléphone fixe mais le développement de
cette solution risque de nous prendre un
peu de temps
enfin nous de bien entendu à l'ecoute de
toute idée pour valider davantage de
comptes tout en restant fiables et
robustes aux attaques de byzantin ne
serait ce encore une fois que pour le
bien d'une propre soleil
alors j'ai parlé jusqu'ici de l'attak
des 51% cependant sur tournesol la
vulnérabilité ne correspondent pas à une
attaque des 51%
pour le comprendre il faut rentrer un
poil plus dans les détails de
l'algorithme utilisé pour calculer les
scores tour ne se ruent en général le
machine learning utilise des algorithmes
d'apprentissage très vulnérable à la
présence d'une unique source de données
byzantine et ça ça vient du fait que les
algorithmes et plus utilisés s'appuie
sur des calculs de moyennes notamment
lors de l'estimation du grade ans pour
ceux qui voient ce dont je parle depuis
quelques années la recherche a beaucoup
avancé pour rendre les algorithmes
d'apprentissage résilient et des sources
de données byzantine recherche dans
laquelle j'ai moi-même été d'ailleurs
impliqué sur tournesol ou s'appuyer sur
cette recherche pour rendre nos ados et
résilient en fait on a même démontré
dans un article qu on est en train de se
mettre dans la version arcade sera
accessible incessamment sous peu nous a
montré dans ce papier est un nombre f2
compte byzantin pour infecter le score
global d'au plus f / 2 points or il y à
des vidéos qui pourrait être noté que
par des comptes byzantin la sécurité du
tournesol
surtout à l'heure actuelle ne dépend en
fait pas de la fraction de byzantin elle
dépend aujourd'hui du nombre de comptes
byzantins sur la plate forme et ça ça ne
m'aide vraiment pas dormir sur mes deux
oreilles au mieux protégé des comptes
byzantin d'autres mesures devront être
prises pour réduire l'influencé maximale
de chaque compte sur les scores
tournesol identifier des vulnérabilités
potentielles détecter les comportements
anormaux généraliser les scores d'un
compte à des vidéos qui n'a pas encore
lu projet le biais de représentation
dans l'ensemble des électeurs il tenir
compte de l'expertisé des contributeurs
parmi tant d'autres projets de recherche
bref tournesol est un immense chantier
mais j'espère que vous êtes convaincus
qu'il s'agit avant tout d'un fabuleux
chantier qui a besoin de vous